Speaker 1: All right, this is a very, very
disturbing clip.
I would encourage you, maybe get the kids
out of the room before I play this clip.
There is a guy named Alex Berenson.
Alex Berenson has been consistently wrong
about just about everything throughout the
pandemic, including vaccines.
Alex Berenson was invited onto the Tucker
Carlson propaganda Fox News show last night,
and Alex Berenson has now made the principled
and defiant statement that the COVID vaccines
should be pulled.
Stop vaccinating everyone, says Alex Berenson,
and Tucker just nods along.
He nods along like his head is on some kind
of swivel.
You have to see this.
This is extraordinarily dangerous.
And remember, for context, this is business
for Fox.
Just about everybody at Fox is vaccinated.
Fox has a much stricter vaccine policy than
the one that Joe Biden attempted to put in
place, which has been struck down by the Supreme
Court.
The Fox policy is even more strict.
This is a business strategy for Fox News.
Let's just jump right in.
Speaker 3: It's we're in a very dangerous
moment, Tucker.
And you know, I'm not exaggerating.
I think this is probably the most important
appearance I've had with you in the last two
years.
It is.
It is completely clear now that the vaccines
don't really work at all against Macron in
in these highly vaccinated and highly boosted
countries, rates of infection are incredibly
high and rates of serious disease and death
are also rising.
The Israelis are predicting that they're going
to have more serious cases than they ever
had at the peak last year.
And the idea that we would solve this with
another booster is is just off the charts.
Insane.
I have not said this to you before because
I'm pretty careful and I'm pretty careful
with the data,
Speaker 1: but that's not
Speaker 3: true.
These vaccines, these RNA vaccines, the many
COVID vaccines need to be withdrawn from the
market now.
No one should get them pull them.
No one should get boosted.
No one should get double boosted.
They are a dangerous and ineffective product
at this point against AMR.
Despite that, they make your body make that
you then produce antibodies, too is not the
al-Muqrin spike.
And earlier today, Tony Fauci said, We're
not going to give people monoclonal antibody
products because the first generation products,
because they don't work against the American
spike.
The same logic applies these RNA vaccines
and giving people boosters, even if in the
very short term, it knocks down infection
rates.
There's a boomerang effect, and that's what
they're seeing in all these countries.
We are in a dangerous moment and these products
need to be withdrawn.
Speaker 1: Pull them all.
Cancel the vaccines now just about every claim
Barris and Berenson makes is false.
But consider how easily, in just 18 seconds,
he's able to set so many fires and consider
then how difficult it is to put those fires
out, particularly in the minds of the Fox
audience, which is very receptive to this
stuff, despite the fact that almost everybody
at Fox News is fully vaccinated now.
As a reminder, this clip aside, Berenson has
been wrong about just about everything during
the pandemic.
He predicted the U.S. would not have 500000
COVID deaths.
We're at almost 900000 already.
He argued that cloth and surgical masks cannot
protect you against the coronavirus at all,
and of course they do to varying degrees.
There's countless peer reviewed studies on
this, including one called an evidence review
of face masks against COVID.
That's in the journal PNAS, which I encourage
you to look at.
He he's been wrong on everything.
He blamed vaccines for causing spikes in severe
illness when, in reality, the vaccines prevent
severe illness.
He blamed the vaccines for suppressing immune
systems, which is a total misrepresentation
of how the immune system works.
He suggested countries like Israel suffered
from rolling out vaccines early, even though
deaths and hospital hospitalizations in Israel
among the vaccinated were so low in that initial
period that he's talking about.
So he's been wrong about everything.
But now he makes these claims to Tucker last
night.
Vaccines don't work at all against Omicron.
That's not true.
We now have extensive data.
The vaccines we currently have are much less
effective at preventing infection from Akron,
but still very effective at preventing hospitalization
and preventing death, which is the point of
vaccines, he says.
Look at.
Or he doesn't say, but if you look at the
rates right now of hospitalization and death
stratified for vaccination status, it is not
even close with Akron almost 100 percent of
cases in the United States.
He says there's more cases in Israel than
at the peak last year.
Well, there's more cases in most places right
now than at their previous peaks.
Because I'm Akron is so contagious, but there's
still a dramatically lower death rate, up
to 90 percent lower, and that lower death
rate is particularly in the vaccinated.
The data are extraordinarily clear.
He says another booster won't solve this well.
Increasingly, people aren't saying take endless
boosters of the same vaccine.
In a couple of months, there will be an Akron
calibrated vaccine, he says.
No one should get a vaccine at all.
The evidence is clear.
You should get vaccinated to lower your chance
of serious illness, lower your chance of ending
up in the hospital and and lower your chance
of ending up dead.
And then, he says.
This is a dangerous product against Akron.
There is no evidence that the vaccines are
dangerous when used to fight Akron, and even
what that means is very squishy and imprecise
language.
This is a.
Very dangerous, guy.
And Tucker has them on, and he just nods and
he just nods.
And at this point, it's abundantly clear Tucker
doesn't believe this stuff.
It doesn't make what he's doing any less pernicious.
In fact, you could argue it makes it more
pernicious because he knows that what this
guy is saying is untrue.
Doesn't matter in the end because the decision
is still being made to put it on the air.
But it's extraordinarily dangerous.
None of it is based in evidence, and we'll
have the clip if you're just listening today.
We'll have that clip of Alex Berenson on our
Instagram, which you can find at David Pakman
show.
You can also follow me on Instagram at David
Pakman.
I posted yesterday a very, very strange message,
not exactly a love letter that I received
from a viewer.
You can find it on my
Instagram at David Pakman.